it's great to be joined today by Rick
Doblin who's the founder and executive
director of maps the multidisciplinary
Association for psychedelic studies a
research and education nonprofit
organization developing legal contexts
for the uses of psychedelics and
marijuana so let's start sort of with
the basics when we talk about I think
people know what marijuana is when we
talk about psychedelics what substances
are under that umbrella that you're
researching and working with well the
word psychedelic was developed in the
50s to mean mind manifesting so we
include LSD psilocybin mescaline
ayahuasca the classic psychedelics but
we also include marijuana and MDMA in
that broad definition and when people
hear oh you're you're studying
psychedelics there could probably be a
few different ways to sort of interpret
what it is that you're doing so tell us
a little bit about the work that the
organization does essentially we are a
nonprofit pharmaceutical company and so
we are trying to develop psychedelics
and marijuana into government approved
prescription treatments and buy
prescription treatments at least for the
psychedelics not marijuana it's
psychedelic assisted psychotherapy so
there'll be a package that will be
approved by the FDA by European
Medicines Agency and other regulators
that is this combination of the drug
plus psychotherapy so we're skipping a
little bit ahead then we'll come back to
the legal context and the limitations on
research but because you talk about in
combination with psychotherapy what type
of professional would you imagine would
be sort of licensed to prescribe
something like this would it be the
professional doing the psychotherapy
would it be a psychiatrist who might be
overseeing a non-medical therapist or
how would that work in your mind well
right now there's these are drugs that
are in Schedule law and the DEA only
licenses physicians to prescribe them
but once they're approved
the FDA and they're moved into schedule
two it will still be limited to
physicians to actually have the licenses
but the professions that will be there
with the patients the doctors will be in
charge of the medical supervision but it
could be psychologists psychotherapists
social workers we work with a
male-female coat therapists team and one
of them have to have a license as a
psychiatrist or psychotherapist but the
other can be a student learning to be a
psychotherapist can be a nurse can be
even somebody that has no license at all
as an assistant but it's basically a
male-female for therapists team that's
with people for the entire psychedelic
session which usually lasts about eight
hours and there's other non drug
psychotherapy sessions before and after
to prepare and to integrate you know bit
we're going to get into you know some of
the possible benefits of this type of
these types of therapies but before we
do that I mean as far as research goes
what can legally be done in terms of
research into some of these uses and and
is the schedule one scheduling of most
of these substances one of the biggest
barriers to really opening research
schedule one of status of these drugs is
a challenge but the FDA is willing to
approve research with scheduled on drugs
the DEA has been willing to give
licenses and institutional review boards
otherwise known as ethics committees our
IRB s have been willing to approve
research so there are extra hurdles to
be researched with scheduled on drugs
but the main limitation is not
regulatory its financial since the drugs
that we're talking about are in the
public domain they're off patent the
uses are also mostly in the public
domain and so we're having to rely on
donations to the nonprofit to fund the
research and we're able to do this
though so far Maps i started in 1986
so 31 years ago we've raised over 40
million dollars during that time and we
anticipating Phase three for our
mdma-assisted psychotherapy for PTSD is
going to cost twenty five million
dollars so those are the main
limitations the fundraising challenges
not so much the regulatory status how
big of an organization are you I mean
how many staff work work with you about
twenty five well so you know a large
group of them are just on our clinical
team managing the research but then we
also have a public education and
communications team we have a harm
reduction team we do work at festivals
to support people of loved difficult
psychedelic experiences we have a small
policy and advocacy team the fundraising
team and we have in operations too so
let's start to dig into the sort of
nitty-gritty question one do have you
tried all of the substances that you're
researching yes oh yeah you have okay
and was there one in particular that you
were most surprised by or had effect
that you didn't anticipate I would say I
was most surprised by MDMA because I
learned about it 1982 and you know I
started doing psychedelics when I was 17
years old in 1971 and 1972 is when I
decided to focus my life on this and I
was very much interested in the mystical
experience the profound depths of the
psyche that you could get into for
psychotherapy and so when I heard about
MDMA in 1982 I was told here's a drug it
helps you to talk with people it helps
you to feel loved it helps you does be a
better listener and I thought you know I
already feel loved I already feel fine I
can talk to people and then I saw a
group of people doing it they were just
sitting in a circle talking to each
other and I was thinking you know what's
profound about that because you know
when you take a fair amount of LSD or
psilocybin you can't even talk you're
having these sort of really profound
nonverbal pre verbal you could even say
deep emotional experiences that are
dissolving your ego and
blending you with the universal other
things and so it really and you may
didn't really impress me but I was smart
enough to buy some it takes some home
and do it with my girlfriend and that's
where I was really shocked at how
profound and deep the experience was and
when you think about the possible
applications of such an experience to
treating medical conditions I begin to
talk to us a little bit about what the
possibilities are what types of
conditions might benefit from the use of
something like MDMA or the other
psychedelics that you're researching
well there's a whole range of
application so MDMA reduces the fear
response to challenging emotions it
reduces activity in the amygdala so it's
very effective in post-traumatic stress
disorder in anxiety disorders and very
many kind of fears or phobias all sorts
of fears of different things I think it
would be very helpful and social anxiety
we've done a study with autistic adults
with social anxiety and show that
mdma-assisted therapy was incredibly
helpful we've done work with people who
are and facing life-threatening
illnesses and they're scared of dying
with MDMA I think it'd be even good for
physical illnesses in some ways like
fibromyalgia or MDMA really opens up the
mind-body connection in a way where I
think it can be helpful for different
kind of ways in which certain emotions
get some a Desai's into the body it'd be
good for depression it's tremendous for
couples therapy but couples therapy is
not a disorder so we're not able to get
it approved by the FDA from all
similarly you can't get drugs approved
by the FDA for personal growth or
spirituality but you can do research
into those areas you just can't get them
approved as medicine that will require
broader reform but psychedelic assisted
psychotherapy has been used particularly
when we talk about LSD or ibogaine or
psilocybin for nicotine addiction
alcohol addiction heroin addiction
opiate other opiates as well these drugs
have a wide range of applications for
emotions that have been
suppress and for helping people have
these spiritual experiences the unit of
connective experiences that can impact
depression anxiety sense of aloneness
and also meaning and purpose let's pick
up our converted conversation there with
dr. Rick Doblin who's the founder and
executive director of the
multidisciplinary Association for
psychedelic studies and we'll continue
on that note tomorrow
we're continuing our conversation with
dr. Rick Doblin the founder and
executive director of maps the
multidisciplinary Association for
psychedelic studies Rick when we left
off we were talking about some of the
possible medical applications of
psychedelics and marijuana I want to now
dig in a little more specifically as to
how some of these substances can be used
if people have googled this topic
generally they've probably come across
the term micro dosing so can you tell us
what is micro dosing micro dosing is
using low very low amounts of the drugs
so low that you don't necessarily know
that you've taken it it doesn't
interfere with your perceptions doesn't
interfere with your logical train of
thought but there's a little bit of an
opening in terms of imagination in terms
of creativity micro dosing particularly
for the classic psychedelics like LSD or
mescaline from peyote or psilocybin for
mushrooms Mike Rinder Singh of those
drugs is used by people in Silicon
Valley for creativity purposes it's used
for people with long lasting sort of low
underlying depression it can give an
energy limp micro dosing is used for
people who want to pay more close
attention to what's happening during the
day and they have a little bit more of a
expansive connection to creativity to
inspiration so we find that it's you
know such low doses that access any
concerns really don't matter and people
are experimenting with it all over the
world down finding quite a different
sort of use however I should say that
it's in contrast to the full dose which
produces this acute experience that can
be deep and profound and then many cases
make it so that people's psyche has
fundamentally changed so that they don't
need to keep doing the large doses micro
doses are meant for sort of long-term
use over extended periods of time but
even
it's not used everyday it's often every
third day different people have
different patterns what's the more
people you mentioned you mentioned
toxicity I mean is it from from a sort
of safety perspective is a micro dose
safer than a full dose well from a
psychological point of view yes these
drugs are not taxed as physiologically
you can't overdose and die on a low
speed
similarly you know ms1 and psilocybin
these are the classic psychedelics are
very safe physically but you could say
there's challenging psychological
effects that come from this ego
dissolution that come from a material
emerging from the unconscious and so
people need to be in a safe and
supportive way when they do full doses
but when you do these micro doses it
doesn't produce those kind of
experiences so you could say it was
safer psychologically and
physiologically to whatever extent there
is any concerns which are really pretty
much non-existent it's just even less of
is the term safe even I mean I guess
it's sort of a confusing term in a sense
I read a reddit AMA that your
organization participated in on this and
there was a line that said we don't
claim that psychedelics or any drugs are
safe but that in particular situations
the benefits outweigh the risks can you
explain that a little bit yeah well
everything has risks and so to say that
there's no risks you know safe implies
no risk you know there was a sad story
of a young man who died practicing
football in the summer here in my town
overheating so you know high school
sports are not safe
nothing is a hundred percent safe but
when we talk about and the FDA you have
to prove safety and efficacy in order to
get a drug approved but it's a balance
it's a relative balance between what's
the benefits and what's the risks and I
think it's kind of a foolish situation
to try to say that there is something
that's perfectly safe people can drown
in
you know is water safe so it's always
the conditions in which you use it
there's there's no such thing as a
substance that is safe that could never
be harmful under any surface so along
those lines what's your sense of how and
actually I'm not even sure that I know
what drug education is currently like in
you know elementary middle and high
school I was in in elementary school
during the time of dare drug drug abuse
resistance education where a cop came in
and basically told us using an analogy
of aliens coming down from a spaceship
and offering you bad things that you
just say no and looking back at it
talking about it with friends it just
seems completely laughable that that
there's any sort of positive impact of
that type of drug education how what's
your sense of how drug education is
taking place now with children and what
effect that has on those children as
adults in terms of the relationship to
drugs well there is still used and in
fact it's used in the local schools here
and all three of my children my youngest
just graduated high school and she had
to go through there and the kind of
research that's been looked at it there
is it's actually harmful in a lot of
cases because they say things that when
you're in fifth grade when you're young
and then they sort of that further kind
of programs in high school they say
things that are not true they exaggerate
the risks they deny the benefits and as
children grow older and realize that
they've been misinformed they start
questioning everything and so all rug
engagements again has lost credibility
and you know who are police officers to
teach science we teach about the effects
of drugs it's a way it's a boondoggle to
get money to police it's designed to
scare children and I think what we
really need is honest and balanced drug
education and we don't have that
currently today still what's your sense
of the legalization of psychedelics I
mean we talk about it's interesting that
it's even police officers as you
mentioned that are teaching this because
marijuana in particular it's been seen
as one of the key sort of law
enforcement issue
over the last who knows how many years
of the war on drugs where do you think
the legalization of psychedelics will
will sort of be if at all within this
legalization movement we're seeing on
marijuana we're assuming psychedelics
will be legal around 2035 so a little
bit less than 20 years we're
anticipating that marijuana will become
legal in the United States on a federal
level around 2024 we're anticipating
that mdma-assisted psychotherapy for
PTSD psilocybin assistant psychotherapy
for depression will become medicines
around 2021
and then they'll be around a decade or a
little bit more than a decade of
psychedelic clinics being established
eventually thousands of them across the
United States every time it has a
hospice Center will one day have a
psychedelic psychotherapy treatment
center and once we've had a bit more
than a decade of medicalization and
people really getting a sense that they
know people that have benefited from it
that they know the risks can be
minimized and the benefits can be
maximized in certain conditions and that
they realized that a lot of the benefits
are not just for people with clinical
indications but it can be looked at as
preventive medicine or personal growth
or spirituality or creativity that we
need to go beyond the medical model so I
think legalization will be 20 35
something like that what do you think
will be the driver of that will it be I
don't know the medical community will it
be local government will it be states to
the point where eventually you get some
kind of federal consensus what will be
the mechanism through which that happens
well I think people will look at the
legalization of marijuana and will try
to learn from that about whether other
drugs should be legalized and I think
what we'll find is that when you have
legalized these drugs you're better able
to control them you're better able to
offer help to those people that have
problems with drugs that they're not
going to be stigmatized we'll be putting
money into drug treatment and treatment
on demand instead of putting people in
prison I think once people realize that
the tax income
that's going to come from the legal sale
of these drugs will more than cover the
problems with these drugs and people
will start to understand the
fundamentally repressive and anti human
rights aspects of policies of
prohibition that people will mature over
the next 20 years they're really
realized that prohibition is
counterproductive and it's not never
really been about stopping drug abuse or
treating drug abuse it's always been
about persecution of minorities and
skate building it's not about public
health and I think once we replace the
criminal justice approach with a public
health approach people will see a lot of
benefits from it we've been speaking
with dr. Rick Doblin founder and
executive director of maps the
multidisciplinary Association for
psychedelic studies thanks so much for
talking to us about this yeah thank you
for having me it's a very important
discussion I'd be very curious what your
listeners have to say about it